check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use a discount code salam 10 for 10
of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah and
welcome back uh brother sisters uh
before i start winning praise allah
subhana wa tala the most merciful the
most trust or praise his glory and
gratitude belong to him um so obviously
a lot of people me myself i don't know
about muhammad hijab but a lot of people
have been pressuring us about
afghanistan's situation and talk about
it why you're not talking about you talk
about everything why are you not talking
about this so i just want to make
something clear first first of all i've
got two brilliant guests here today for
brother rahmatullah naraz and sister
marwah uh brother i know brother brother
um i think we have met a couple of times
and he's bought me a gift as well which
is afghan clothing he hasn't given to me
yet but in october he'll be given and
i'll be definitely trying it on and
maybe a little youtube video sister
mario is someone i do not know but i did
do a request um on my instagram because
i thought it's important to have a
sister's take uh sister marwah is from
uh she's afghani um and yeah she's gonna
be um adding some things inside a lot of
things to this discussion so today i'm
going to be a student and i'm going to
have sister marwah and brother
rahmatullah as my teachers who are going
to educate me to the whole thing that's
been escalating and what's been going on
so may allah bless both of you guys
salaam alaikum
okay so
you are in malaysia
i'm in germany right now all right
you're in germany i've moved to germany
since three years
oh wow i don't know i'm sorry i don't
even know where i am sometimes myself
that's fine that's good sister marwah
you are from
california you're from california okay
um all right so
tell us a bit about yourself not in
detail um you're both afghani yeah so
an opportunity to speak about
afghanistan
uh i'm heavily involved in afghanistan
alhamdulillah i'm running the
organization in fact two organizations
afghanistan with more than 50 employees
and also a number of schools my own
family
i'm the only person from the family
who's outside afghanistan so the
situation i'm aware i'm following in
closing
and inshallah this session will be
beneficial because i have interacted
with the previous government with the
current regime
and i've met right from the ministers to
the governors and i've worked with them
with each one of them and inshallah
we'll be sharing those stories uh my
interaction with the previous ministers
and interaction with the current regime
right now uh and i'm based in germany so
that's all i think for this discussion
okay
uh um brother for having this seminar
discussion
um
i am based in california
um i have never been to afghanistan but
i am
a young adult who wants to speak out for
her country and especially the women
there because there are many uh bias and
propaganda going around on instagram
facebook twitter um on all of these
social media platforms
and i would like to say a few words
about those okay that's good excellent
so can i ask both of you guys a question
did you guys because you said he was not
born in afghanistan sister marwah did
your family like did they when did they
leave is it because of the war or is it
just outside the war uh same question to
you brother rahmatullah after inshallah
system yeah
yeah so um just hearing from my dad and
my mom's uh stories uh they left to be
once the first time the taliban came to
kabul so um the situation wasn't
good and my parents uh did not want
their kids growing up in such a place
with war
and crime so they decided to
come to tajikistan and then after
tajikistan they
illegally
went from tajikistan to russia and then
from russia we came to uh america so
when was this this was what 20 years ago
25.
19 1996.
okay yeah so about about 20 years ago
okay
did you you or your family was there a
reason specifically you left afghanistan
because of that
um i did not leave for because of the
war my whole family is there i'm the
only person from my family that was
outside of pakistan and i went to
malaysia for educational purposes and
then i moved to germany for
uh family reasons but it wasn't because
of work
okay um and you i uh sister mario you're
from kabul your family
yes okay and brother rahmatullah you're
from
which is a bit uh remote uh province
from kabul but we are living in kabul my
family is living kabul
okay so what's your okay so let's go 20
20 plus maybe years ago um or exactly 20
years ago actually in september it's
gonna be 9 11 happens how did it impact
you um sister maro i don't know how old
you was then but
i don't know if you remember it but how
did it impact both of you guys because
it did impact muslims as a whole i can
remember when that happened i used to
live outside london i was not a muslim
and i i was getting abused you know
because i looked muslim um so how did it
impact you both
yeah sure um so when 9 11 happened i was
1 years old
so i don't remember that much but just
hearing from my dad and my mom's
perspective
when we were in russia
we in russia my dad
he had like in russia there was a lot of
racism against muslims and so when when
9 11 happened that kind of escalated to
its max uh to the point where my dad
when he would go to work he would have
to um
either take me or my
younger siblings because the police
would stop him um so that's that but i
don't really remember like from my own
personal experience i don't remember an
iphone
okay um
before 9 11 i would like to give them a
bit of background why 911 happened why
america invaded afghanistan and so on
and so forth yeah
just to i'm not going to speak with more
statistics and dates and year i will go
with the flow of the discussion so it's
easy for everybody to understand what
happened yes please yeah
it wasn't the trade center which made
america invade afghanistan
okay
it
america was involved in afghanistan from
1991. soviet the soviet yes
they were funding the mujahideen through
pakistan and saudi arabia to fight
against the soviet union yes and when
they fought the money was given as a
form of donation of zakat so and so
forth from people from the gulf
countries like imarat saudi
channeling through pakistan to
afghanistan
and there were camps in pakistan which
were
the training centers the camps which
a lot of famous camps in uh in peshawar
as well as in uh
in the whole area of camps which were
actually famous for this work
they funded that money to fight the
soviet union and in 1991 soviet union
collapsed and they were forced to leave
afghanistan and the funding which was
given to the government through swedish
union of course that funding stopped the
government had nothing and their banks
or reserve
so the sweden syria the russians are
gone and najibullah government was in
power
so what happened those mujahideens which
were funded by the americans the
americans were closely involved with
them but they took tribalism like
pashtun tajik uzbak and
hazara they took tribalism and they
fought each other
because of power one want to become the
prime minister second wanted to become
the minister or the president they were
fighting each other to a degree
that the rape was common
the blocks and every road was there
for example pashtun wouldn't be able to
travel to
tajik area tajik won't be able to travel
to pashtun area
uh my sister is here i'm sorry to say
that they literally chop the breast of
women in front of their men so they can
degrade them what they did they chopped
their heads both parties
all the warlords were involved in
killing machines in fact there were
roadblocks and the man would stand
without any pant and would tell you when
you're crossing that road block either
you pay me money i will rape your woman
in front of you
the man of the standing without any
pants can you believe that
in fact there were famous people which
happened to later become the parliament
mps
known by the dogs because you used to
eat and bite people
and chop their meats with their teeth
that was the situation what happened and
ca was heavily involved with these world
lords supporting them for example among
them was steve cool
uh black cooper they were literally and
working with other alliance
and forming
different groups in that area
so what happened in 1994
the first military operation started by
taliban in kandahar
to defend the people the ordinary people
from these warlords and to protect them
and actually this started with the rape
case of a girl who was raped forcefully
and this is a true story if i'm a war
lord and i see your wife is beautiful i
will just knock your door and take your
wife and kill you
that's the true story i mean people can
label you whatever they wanted so there
was no jihad no islam whatsoever
in a group taliban were mostly people
who were
sent by their parents to pakistan to
learn islamic education they were in
madrasas so in kandahar the first
activity started defend a innocent girl
who was raped by a warlord
and then the movement started and
pakistan the situation is a great
movement why not we send all the
students from madrasas they send them so
in 1996 in september they took over the
government
why people supported them because they
were less corrupt they were saying okay
we are going with the
sharia law and we will not harm anybody
protect everyone there will be safety
and what happened in those areas even in
the time of taliban were in power they
couldn't control the northern side of
afghanistan like northern alliance which
was panchayat parwan and these are they
were not controlled and especially those
era muslim led by famous commander
masood masood
and cia was literally funding those
people to fight the taliban at the same
time working with some areas of the
talib with some of the talibans to make
sure that the country is not going in
the hands of russians again or the
chinese don't come over and there are
economical reasons which we will discuss
later on yeah which was a pipeline from
tajikistan we'd call it tapi
which involves pakistan india in
afghanistan and afghanistan was a core
strategic location for that pipeline so
therefore they need to have somebody who
can they trust in that area so in 9 11
it could be a debatable matter we can
debate it today but we don't have to do
that and i don't have to go into details
911
wasn't uh something that was done by the
afghani people none of the citizens were
afghan non-iraqi they were mostly saudi
citizen
and they took that as a point of
a reason to attack iraq and afghanistan
and then libya i personally believe as
professor steve
steve cool that they believe that 9 11
was inside job it was a reason for
america to you know allow themselves to
go to the iraq and go to the afghanistan
and have war and when 11 happened
sorry you know there's a website called
rethink rethink911 i can remember when i
was looking into islam i was i joined
this group called reefing 911. it was 2
000
individual experts and then there were
demolition experts and scientists who
were basically going against his own
narrative you know how the buildings
fell
to world trade center seven falling down
feel for
free fall
with just office fire uh the pentagon
being hit no cameras um the whole of the
pentagon like the wings there's so much
stuff it's unbelievable there's a whole
discussion about did this even happen uh
of the way it happened let alone was um
afghanistan involved when it was a saudi
citizen
that was doing it so it's all mishmash
but regardless that's our discussion on
its own yeah let's let's even say that
happens let's agree on that part with
most people that they say it happened it
happened okay fine so why did did they
invade afghanistan because of osama bin
laden and interestingly enough you could
find other means
to
pressure a country to give up individual
like you can stop the financial
institution yeah you can blacklist them
you can work at them you can do tariff
on them there are hundreds of other ways
which are non-war related ways that you
can pressure the country to give up an
individual that's number one they're
doing with iran
they're dealing with iran and that we
will come to those discussions anyway
yeah so they did not do that they came
to afghanistan
and without the approval of even
security council of united nation there
was no approval uh it wasn't discussed
publicly in terms of that there were
three reasons why they came to
afghanistan number one was economical
reason
that the defense contractor were making
huge amount of money we will talk about
them spending in afghanistan
and number two the geographical location
they want to have a
close contact with russia and china so
they had to be there and also they want
to keep control pakistan in order so
yeah they're there in area so they
invaded in afghanistan once they invaded
i remember i was i was born in
1993 the first missile hit our province
not closely we were living in larman it
hit in jalalabad and the american
invaded nobody knew and the discussion
was going on for the airspace and the
land they discussed with india and the
india couldn't agree they discussed with
pakistan pakistan agreed and there were
people involved i don't have to go to
the details of each person who was
involved in um nawaz sharif and all
those people yeah so they invaded
afghanistan so what they did i'm going
to jump on the point they again brought
those people those warlords which was
despised by the people and gave ways to
taliban to come and put them in the
position and the authority and make them
for example the people they they kill
the whole uh taliban regime they kill
half a million children more than one
million were killed
and they brought the same people people
like okay let me make this a dis
disclaimer i have to make this
i'm speaking from no sites i'm not on
side of taliban near side of the
previous government or current
government i'm an independent afghan
who is independently working in
afghanistan yeah and uh the only thing
that i'm happy that the invasion is over
but i'm not taking any side if i'm
taking names it does not mean
that i'm against somebody else
whatsoever i'm merely recording the
history and those history which are
you know the documented history anybody
who want to check some of the books i
can reference him and they can check and
read it but i'm going to speak as well
so names like dustin who was warlord who
killed documented by bbc five thousand
taliban were surrendered to what's his
name
is this the guy who fled to turkey
yes so he's in turkey now
no no he's in tajikistan
he's in he fled to tajik somehow he's a
war criminal like he's done like they
say i don't know stories i heard stories
that he put 5000 taliban into a
container
and threw them in the desert and some
kind i don't i heard i don't know how
true it is yes i mean i can go in
details of each person but i'm just
merely quoting okay
so they put those people in power
and the families were killed they did
not bother about the families of taliban
okay every taliban he has a son grandson
whatsoever what will happen to them yeah
they put all those people in power
corruption on the rise and why
put the corruption in order so they can
channel the money back to america
like each person was earning a monthly
salary sixty thousand
two hundred thousand my father was sub
governor of nurisan
sub gold in the third position
afghanistan is a big position so i
personally talked to americans to the
army and mostly were subcontractors by
the army like blackwater titan and casey
they were the subcontractor and each
army person he had salary of sixty
thousand thirty thousand monthly salary
can you believe that wonderfully wow
simple people and the reason they are
saying okay you know we are funding
afghanistan we spend this much money
that money was channeled back to america
like can you believe in the camp i've
personally visited the american camps in
afghanistan they called base
a cup of pepsi do you know perhaps you
would cost 49
in the camp in the outside you can buy
it with 50 cent oh my gosh
washing your clothes washing your
clothes one pair of clothes would cost
you hundred dollar inside the cam
but outside the cam it would cost you 10
cent
so that's how they channel the money
they brought they send the money to
afghanistan
and then they channel it back through
themselves and their contractors to send
it back to america so that's one story
so 911 in general
we will go on the next phrase that if it
destroyed the whole country
it kills
more than million people
every day 9 11 in america was every day
and i live in afghanistan no place was
safe
and american they
put wrong people in power yeah
corruption was the highest level which
we will of course in discussion talk
about it and many
family were lost in the country
infrastructure and the zero and then
they're saying we have spent the money
where is none of the uh you don't have
infrastructure in the country and most
money was spent in the defense which was
channeled back to america can i ask
sister maro did your family um
did your family did you have any family
casualties like or people that you knew
uh when
let's talk about
before america i don't know if you know
like if you if you knew that before
americans
arrived to after the americans arrived
did you have any family casualties like
for example because of the war
yeah when my dad was there um he told me
a story about himself he was i believe
20 and he was going to school
um he was on one of those uh
i don't know you would call it like the
big buses yeah and um
the uh
the america i believe it was the
american team where the soviet union
take one of them he they just came right
on top of the bus
and anyone who was in front of the bus
literally just died and my dad was in
the back so the front seat came upon his
um
uh legs and he still has scar until this
day and somehow he was able to get out
um
was that was that a bomb attack
no it was just a tank going over the
bottom oh a tank going over them yes oh
my gosh
yeah
surprised and you know do you have
family members like for example when
taliban was ruling you know because we
do see these images of women in absolute
burkas where even the eyes covered
and you know these images you know the
western world was sharing of you know
these women who were there and they're
going to be stoned today for some kind
of i don't know how much you know about
this but any female family members did
they ever mention to you how the taliban
treated them you know
so so back uh back then when the when
the taliban first came i heard stories
like from my family members that they
were pretty strict like they had curfew
in place
um women were not allowed to go outside
without a male partner
um
they did have to wear the full burqas
like the
the blue hijabs that you guys see
um
and yeah i believe i didn't hear about
like any stoning or any of that but um
i mean i do see it from the western
media
but now
um i'm hearing that they're more
open-minded
and um i mean if you watch the the
biggest newscast of afghanistan which is
called news
the reporter was a woman
and uh she was interviewing a taliban so
um so yeah
rahmatullah so do any of you like how
was it i don't know if you know yourself
but by any family female family members
um when taliban were talking about
taliban 20 years ago maybe or you know
how were they then is it true like you
know they wouldn't allow girls to go to
school
um and then all these accusations i
don't know is it true can you educate me
taliban from 1996 to 2001 uh they were
all
people who came from mother son
and young individuals they barely passed
30s
and they were implementing they've they
thought they'd be implementing sharia
but it was no longer sharia
they were trying to implement sharia but
it was no longer sharia it was an
extreme form of sharia that it was no
longer the book of allah implemented
yeah for example people get beat up for
their beard being shot for not wearing
turban
uh for female not going to uh
you know for female going to school
education so and so forth that part of
the
history and no no doubt that they had
huge problems they had huge huge
problems and stuff can we say instead of
using i'm i'm not blaming you i know
what you're trying to say but to instead
of using because they can come across
wrong extreme form of sharia can we say
that it was a lack of the sharia there
was
missing because you know as i said
earlier they were using extreme form it
was no longer sharia exactly yeah so
it's no longer because i know some
people are gonna because they already
have the specific
when you say they're thinking but
there's different levels now they they
went there there's no level i said they
were using extreme form which was no
longer no longer sharia that's it yes
yes
so
those rules and internally they had
problems they had like bachelor's
problem
uh you know having boys around them
which was a big problem they had problem
i mean we can list them and most of the
thing which of course the media is
saying it's not 100 true but they did
have problems like
can you elaborate i'm so sorry can you
just elaborate you know the banjo-bazi i
don't need to go into detail but there
might be some people they don't know
what you're talking about
and because the thing is it's
you don't need to go into detail but
there are warlords who would use these
boys
who were i think dressed as
i don't i don't know i've seen like even
yes they the bachabazi is a local term
which basically mean that you're use
you know we have this uh gay system
which you can label very nicely but in
afghanistan
okay so basically it's a
person who is a word lord who is a
commander who is a powerful guy he has
one or two boys and he sleeps with them
he makes them dance and blood and so and
so forth so that was the term
they had that problem which was very
common unfortunately the second problem
they had was
the the treatments of women towards the
education so and so forth the treatment
of men and it was the judgment was only
on the table whatever a man decided
that's a judgment there was no proper
government system no proper jesus system
and the other problem that they were
facing is that following one opinion
always that was the only opinion they've
believed and they couldn't agree with
other opinions yeah so of course they
had uh many problems and now
they've come completely different people
but i would say it's two early
to accept what they're saying
they're merely words yeah we haven't
seen them in action so we will see them
in action we will discuss of course we
have time we will go through that
details as well okay sister mara um so
do you trust for as a muslim woman
do you trust what the taliban is saying
when it comes to for example
well how they're going to treat women
because at the end of the day let's be
honest here you know we don't care who
it is you know and then they you know we
have to be just here um like what they
were doing before like woman not allowed
to be educated
not work all this kind of stuff i mean
this is very far from the sharia you
know um
you know and then yes you know we know
the process did say that the best place
for a woman is at home except this
doesn't mean you don't let them go out
because you know we know um
boycotted his son because his son said
i'm not going to let my wife go to the
masjid
he said this is yeah against the sunnah
so the thing is here um
even appointed a woman to manage the
markets so the thing is we are that we
can see and we know how
i want to say harsh but you know how the
um
was and you know him to appoint um
someone a female to manage the markets
etc and even there's a narration
that says that you know once he was
corrected by the same woman when it came
to the maher of the uh females you know
when he said that women were asking for
too much mahara and the woman quoted the
quran ayah and he said no this is the
right of what allah has given us you
know
said the woman is right and umar is
wrong and if we look and this is what we
see the beauty of islam in you know
people think the more you make haram and
everything is haram that means you're
following the correct islam everything
is haram everything is restricted and
this is not the case because we know the
sun of the prophet is that he would
always pick an easier option so as a
muslim woman do you think what the
taliban are saying can you are you can
you trust them um have they really
changed have they learned a lesson have
they come to the correct understanding
of islam are you skeptical
um well it's really hard to say now
because it's only been like a week or
like five days that they have you know
taken over the land and i mean so far
what i've been watching um
on youtube there's this guy called
homoyunovan he's an interviewer and he's
on the ground in afghanistan and
he
interviewed
the taliban there currently right now
and he also interviewed like people
uh regarding like are you scared um do
you fear them
um and the majority of them you know say
positive things about them so i mean i
personally don't care who's you know um
ruling the land as long as
secular governments are no longer there
right and as long as the law of allah is
being applied there right and and i know
for some woman here in the west that's
i'm so sorry sister marrow forgive me
for i mean just to me like a lot of
people watching this i mean the western
world watching a muslim woman 21 years
old marwa in california saying that she
wants the secular law out of there it's
like i mean we came there to rescue you
we came there to you know you know the
white man's burden you know we came
there to you know save you and away from
this oppresses
taliban and you're here you you want
sharia law and you don't want a secular
government can you elaborate on that
because that to me is profound you know
someone watching this in the west are
going to be like you know gobsmacked
yeah yeah
um well if you think about it um
it's 21 right
and women
cannot go to school get a job go to the
beach or accompany their children right
but if they go against what they are
ordered to wear and will end up getting
fined or arrested right and here i'm not
talking about afghanistan i'm talking
about france right so
if you think about it
in afghanistan right um
people like women here in the west think
that freedom and not being oppressed
comprises of not wearing the hijab right
not like going out with a male companion
and all that right but this is
this is
like this is all of what allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala compromised within the sharia
law right and um
for some
young adults especially here in the us
this is hard to take in
because they haven't been educated on
their deen because they haven't been um
you know seen the the actual islam for
what it is right um they've always seen
men with bearded guys and guns holding a
gun over a woman right which is coming
from mainstream media from the west well
of course the the the america admitted
that they spend a half a billion pounds
on fake propaganda videos half a billion
not a million 500 million pounds on fake
propaganda videos just to touch upon
someone assistant you said something
about uh females not being able to go to
school with hijabs etc some people might
think you're talking about afghanistan
i'm assuming you're talking about maybe
france if i'm not mistaken yeah yes
france just to clarify that because you
know when you talk about they're not
allowed and this that the first thing
that comes to people's mind is taliban
here we go again actually we're talking
about france here but yeah carry on
please
yeah so i mean um my only advice for
my fellow afghans and muslims here in
the us
and in the west in general is to be
careful about your sources right i see
people posting and reposting stuff
um like there was a cartoon picture of
this girl and she was holding her piano
and she was wearing the burqa and then
behind her
was um a bunch of taliban carrying guns
on top of her like what this shows me
is that
before we even allow the taliban
currently to even implement what they're
trying to implement right we're already
coming to conclusion because of what
happened to the past right exactly
yeah like you can't do that that's
exactly there was a woman who escaped
afghanistan and she i think there was a
little glimpse of it was on bbc and she
was she's like
we came here the taliban's going to kill
us woman like she was like probably
dramatic and and i i think it was
fear-mongering can't even really blame
her and in the context where yes the
taliban before may have been oppressive
i don't know about killing may have been
really oppressive towards the woman
which is against the
the sharia
you know very clearly so they were very
very um scared you know subhanallah so i
think there is some kind of
indoctrination uh where this where
people are scared that people are
holding onto planes when i saw that
video of people falling off the planes
well i i thought that's not real that's
photoshopped and i couldn't believe that
actually people were holding onto that
plane you know and i did
brother raphael maybe you can correct
this for me but that whole mayhem
happened in that airport because the
people were told that the west are
accepting refugees or something along
those lines that is the reason why am i
correct to say that that it wasn't
because they were running from taliban
but it was that they were told that the
doors were open to the western world
is that correct yes
yeah that's correct actually this
disaster is also created by western
countries like taliban have announced
harmless uh the forgiveness they've
forgiven everyone in afghanistan but i
would say taliban forgiveness from other
people as well because they have also
killed and heard innocent
civilians in afghanistan
what the western countries they did what
they do right now they're actually
planning in that way yeah they have
spent money on educating people and now
they're announcing every country that
i'm accepting 20 000 people without
passport without visa just come to the
airport yeah and many people are coming
there not because they're scared of
taliban yeah just because they want to
have access to the west economical
markets so on and so forth and the
second thing is what they do they want
to take all the educated people the
skills workers so once they're
they're gone and the country is empty
with people because we only have 20
people who are educated 80 percent are
not educated yes if you take the 20
percent then what left there coming to
the woman part
there is a huge uh hypocrisy
unfortunately when we are talking about
women rights and we are only when we
talk about women rights we go to the
muslim countries like yemen or somalia
uh we go to afghanistan in pakistan and
those countries yeah but let's talk
about women rights in the western
countries
they are getting their rights no for
example in germany the country that i'm
living every hour there's a domestic
case against a woman every other right
now we spoke one domestic has already
happened in america there are 130
million people with hiv diseases the
single motherhood even even in london
one they say that there's one million
people in london that have some kind of
sexual disease
yeah i mean look at the the single
motherhood case look at the streets of
california yeah london the homeless we
do not have a single homeless woman in
afghanistan yeah but if they're also
women please respect them and give them
some rights now if we come to
afghanistan again the hypocrisy
continues with their clothing
if they wear the clothes and the western
countries there are subjugated they have
been forced to wear these clothes if
they pushing it to not wear in
afghanistan so if the same woman she's
choosing to wear in afghanistan yeah
then it's a problematic it's fine if
she's not wearing it it's not fine
i don't know the hypocrisy level is very
high in the vessel
white man's burden yeah yeah i've heard
of that actually syndrome is it syndrome
like what was it called
israel is it white man's birth and
syndrome yeah i think we should have
another one's white woman's burden
syndrome because this is all you know
feminists coming to rescue the i think
it can be muslim
broadcast
it can be a big podcast for example in
saudi arabia so they were chopping heads
they were not concerned about that but
they were concerned about driving yeah
for example right now you should not be
concerned about women educated in
afghanistan they are all married they
all have children they have beautiful
life nobody is single in afghanistan you
have single motherhood case in the whole
america solve that first if you're
concerned about human lives then go to
africa solve their humanitarian cases
give them facilities for the laborers
and to live at least be safe millions of
women are dying every year the education
is more important or life is more
important exactly i think they should
take care of these matters first before
they point out fingers to afghanistan
exactly let's talk about afghanistan
yeah no definitely you know you have
people absolutely hypocrites a fake
ex-muslim there's this woman called
yasmin i don't know what her name is an
absolute you know hypocrite you know um
she's there to talk about women's rights
and stuff like that and she lives in
america and i'm just trying to find the
article here as i'm speaking that's why
i was scrolling uh not that i was a
listener i was listening to you
basically there was a cj world roland i
think that's what his name is and he
made a point where he was talking about
i'm trying to find it here there are
some stats that he gave about 50 000
women per day or something like that the
force of prostitution and all this kind
of stuff in the american world if you
look into the american world with the
with the porn industry and what is going
on on a pandemic level where you have
people you know incest levels you know
people who are
so sorry sister well i please forgive me
and and well i do not but i don't want
to go into details it's crazy the stuff
that's going you know um against the
muslim against the western women you
know they are made to feel so ugly i'm
reading a book called beauty sick i mean
if you watch that if you read that um
the offer is basically talking about the
sickness that these young girls have
that they are fasting you know we fast
as muslims in ramadan yeah these girls
are systematically fasting to have the
perfect body they are not happy with
their self they can't go out without
makeup they are doing plastic surgery
that is killing them i read the article
where a brazilian woman or whoever
they're going to get certain implants
and they die in the process i mean
they're literally dying and they come
here and making it seem as the muslim
woman is the you know the one who needs
help when you are drowning you're
literally drowning and you're here
trying to help someone else so there is
big hypocrisy happening there
and these people are just taking uh
advantage
i have four sisters yeah yeah and i've
never heard from them or from other
relatives relative mind that they are
going through some sort of depression
when i came to the west and talked to
every sister she is going through some
sort of depression either she is
insecure from her body from her look or
she's insecure because she doesn't have
a boyfriend
or people men are not looking at her
wallahi the disaster that's happening to
female in the western countries the
pressure that they are under
i mean the subjugation that they are
getting right now here they have been
sexually objectified that that's not a
concern of the media but what's the
concern if a girl is going to the school
in advance or not that's the concern
they really care about problems yeah do
they really care about that let's be
honest here yeah
did america and the western world
go to afghanistan because the most
because the muslim woman there were not
allowed to go schools and are being
oppressed let's be real here did the
american sister marwah do you believe
that the american government and the
british government and the australian
government and these governments who
have committed war crimes they have
committed war crimes that a this this
absolute scumbag feel free this there's
a guy called harris sultan an absolute
scumbag
actually well he was trying to get me
banned from australia check this out
yeah one of the reasons he wanted to be
banned from australia which i'm going to
go australia and i'm going to take a
picture with a kangaroo and send it to
him anyways yeah while having coconut
water um he wanted me banned the reason
he wanted me banned is because he this
is his accusation so he's he's
complaining to the australian government
about me and here's the following ali
dawa accusing the australian government
of war crimes
australia itself if i'm not mistaken
very sure there was an article they
themselves accept that walking has
happened but you haven't admitted you
have this guy who has you know he's an
insecure white boy wannabe
this insecure guy who's trying to suck
up to the australian government by
saying hey look man he's accusing you
guys of war crimes with the australian
government themselves the point i'm
trying to make here is how insignificant
the muslim life is in in his eyes so
much so that he is trying to defend the
australian government which he is a ref
he was a refugee yeah he was a refugee
who uh um claimed asylum there yeah
probably because of the false pretense
of i'm an ex-muslim they want to kill me
you know like we've got nothing better
to do and go after uh little um
intellectual midgets like you you know
so the thing is and i've seen his
instagram he keeps posting muscles like
a very insecure guy like
his debate all his instagram was about
muscles so you can see he's a very
insecure person but what really caught
my eye was that not just his instagram
most of his pictures yeah most of his
pictures i live the jahili life yeah
okay i had moments of my life when i was
a bit insecure and i would always take
pictures in the gym like oh look at my
muscles oh look at me i look so you know
and all these pictures are like
it's trying to seem uh strong and
there's there's a statement you know the
stronger you try to look the weaker you
are but anyways let's move away from
this little boy um yes
i just want to comment on this i have
debated him in 2009. what the boy if you
had it yeah the boy
the boy
the boy yes okay yeah okay
i've debated him and i asked him for on
the atheistic ground what reason do you
have to not kill people and he was
actually
i mean no no to you to your world view
i'm so sorry sister we're going to have
a tangent here according to his world
view
him and and i'm not even getting my
phone my phone's my intelligence
him and my socks are the same thing yes
you know what's the difference between
me
destroying my socks and destroying him
yeah unless they are physically they're
both made of atoms and it's just a
rearrangement of atoms and to his world
view he has no grounds to even talk
about morality
little boy anyway he's a major anyway
let's move away from this little boy
actually yeah i will come back on the
afghanistan this woman issue so actually
i was debating another australian
ex-muslim and she told me that islam is
saying wear your clothes i say
secularism saying take off your clothes
it's the same thing
so where's your choice
you said she said i want to be free i
said so where's your choice islam is
saying where is secretary take it off so
where's your choice no do you know
what's important brother uh rahmatullahi
check this out here people come you know
a lot of sisters come and say um i
choose to wear the hijab and i go no you
don't choose to wear the hijab you wear
the hijab because allah told you to i
don't choose to grow the beard allah
told me to i don't choose to wake up for
fajr i don't say her today i choose to
wake up for fajr no allah told me to but
what they misunderstand is the they make
it seem like the western world i'm not
saying all of them yeah they make it
seem as if they have a free choice to
wear mini skirts no you don't no you
don't because i i i used to do uber and
i would pick certain customers where
they would take off their heels and they
were carrying their hands and they would
walk barefooted like like like some of
them like you know like caveman used to
walk barefooted i'm not saying they are
here and before anyone starts thinking
i'm attacking them what i'm trying to
say is they would walk because they're
bleeding and if you're dressed up like
that in winter are you really choosing
to or are you programmed to by the
beauty industry which is a multi-billion
pound industry that is making you feel
insecure and ugly and so much so that
you have to meet these demands so the
question that needs to be asked is do
you choose to or are you forced to if
you are told what to think how couldn't
you tell me you're free
so that's what they don't understand and
because they're
subconsciously programmed um and coerced
into this they think they have a choice
what they don't realize is that you are
coerced into this without realizing
let me comment on the afghanistan issue
of the woman yes so
certain things which were actually
socially and culturally
every country need time to grow and to
come to a certain level just like saudi
was not allowing women to drive it
wasn't because of religion it was a
culture
similarly in afghanistan it wasn't
because of the religion they didn't want
their women to go to universities or
other places it was mostly culture and
now american can't say you have iphone
10 afghanistan it's me because i invaded
you and i brought your iphone 10. yeah
so it was actually the culture around
the world just west have been through
the same culture same period we all
every country the same period in
afghanistan the period was 1991 because
of the war and then from post 2000
people have grown up they have educated
they were educated not only women even
men were not educated yeah post 2000 men
got educated they went on to
universities other places to get
education but right now taliban they
have said uh that we would allow women
to come on the tv they will allow them
to go on education uh
take the education go to universities i
mean they have said it it's and they
can't even ban it because if the event
people won't accept it you understand
okay so that's the concern that um
western countries should leave you to
the afghan let them decide between
themselves women our mothers they are
sisters they are their wives we respect
them and we would never take away their
rights if a woman is uneducated then the
whole family is uneducated exactly we
would definitely everybody would want
their wife and sister to be educated so
that's not the concern the western
countries should have i would suggest a
personal countries can leave us alone
and just mind their own business no i
will generally bake them a cake i don't
even know how to bake it but i will
learn it and back to my cake and give it
to them as a thank you message exactly
you know not just afghanistan leave the
whole middle east alone yes
we've got 10 minutes 11 minutes because
i'm going to operate margaret um
i forgot what's going to say uh yeah so
what was i going to say
okay let's touch upon uh for example um
the death toll that happened in
afghanistan let's touch upon that
inshallah let's give it five minutes so
if i'm not mistaken about a million
people were killed in iraq yeah
massacred in iraq here we know people
like wikileaks leaked this information
and now he's on the run you know freedom
of speech
yeah um but it's okay so he's on the run
and
afghanistan we're talking about half a
million people that will kill two yeah
actually more than enough we can be more
than that
a million people yeah
yeah these are just yeah yeah exactly
these these are we're generous here yeah
half a million people killed
and what happened and look at this the
america americans leave and in a matter
of days
the matter of days taliban take full
control
was the government let's talk about
actually about the government as well
was the government corrupt before
okay if you do you want me to start
you can't we've got let's let's give
that four minutes
okay so i have met ministers okay
minister of education minister of uh
foreign affairs minister of technology
every minister because i'm heavily
involved in afghanistan
we have big big projects so one time i
asked a minister to give me a land to
build orphanage a governor as well
he told me since you're doing sharia
work in islamic work i will speak from
sharia perspective clearly that i will
take 40 000 from you
40 000
as a bribe
so for you to do something islamic or to
build the orphanage oh my god can you
believe it
so there were 4 billion
every year that was the level of bribe
people are paying 4 billion oh my gosh
every year and i would tell you there is
nothing
that
people are easily asking for money
so that the corruption was in highest
level and you cannot imagine corruption
was the highest level only few people
they had the money because they were on
the top position
if you want to be governor there was a
price tag for that if you want to be
governor 150 000 you need to pay if you
want to be mp you have to pay like 300
000
was literally look i'm speaking from the
i'm not saying i'm a nobody my father
was sub-government
i'm heavily involved in afghanistan
government with the people and not as a
part of their team whatsoever because we
have projects there so everything the
price tag was there if you want to do
this price tag i want to get a shortcut
from the minister
and the person asked me that you need to
give us money i complained to the
minister i personally met him my
pictures are there yeah and he told me
you know what even if i need to do
something in other department i have to
bribe them so give them the money
so that's the level of corruption was
there actually do you think taliban will
put an end to this corruption
hundred percent
why is it something why how could you
trust them so easy why hundred percent
because the aid is they're controlling
there's a justice there's no corruption
and there's no bribery
in the street of kabul which were
controlled by 40 countries including the
african government you could not work
with your iphone people literally chop
your hand and check your iphone no way
yes
you could not work with your own
when i when i was in afghanistan i
personally two bodyguards
with machine guns
i'm not a big guy just to protect my
iphone
my car
oh my gosh my watch
me and hijab go afghanistan can we have
four bodyguards
[Laughter]
bribery
justice and the justice will serve if
you know the big guys yeah you weren't
secure if you don't know big guys you're
not secure
people couldn't build guys are you
talking about me big guys
i'm talking about hijab and you not
physically i mean big guys meaning that
if you have a power with the government
so the corruption level was there and
the country was not in their control
okay and nobody followed the law okay
sister marwa i want to ask you a
question here basically we're going to
wrap up in about five six minutes i'm
going to go pray um
look the taliban people say the taliban
is putting their face on yeah okay like
i said before i don't know nothing about
taliban i'll be honest i don't know all
i know taliban means like the the talib
like knowledge seekers or something like
that yeah so the thing is here why would
taliban who's got full power now
want to put a
face
a two-face um by saying we're going to
give women why would they do that if
they have the power
why would they do that what are they
fearing because the americans have left
they've got full power they are more
richer than ever because all the one
trillion plus pounds the american and
their guns and everything they left is
now war beauty for um afghanistan the
taliban what are they afraid of to even
give these false promises because the
last videos i saw of them was in bumper
cars and the gym doing exercise um and
some of them were doing the exercise a
bit wrong but the thing with me i'll
bless like like bless them in the
context where it's just mesquite like
how you see where he was he was using
the leg machine for bicep kills but the
thing is um the thing is here that why
are they what are they afraid of to give
false promises
um
i personally don't think that they're
putting on a two-face um just seeing
from what like people in afghanistan are
saying
but
if they are even putting on a two-face
um it's either because they want to get
everyone on their side so the people of
afghanistan on their side
and um because right now like the
majority of people like that you saw
jumping on airplanes running um
at the airport right it's because they
have a history or they know the history
of taliban and how they were oppressive
committed war crimes against their own
people right
but
i truly believe in and sha allah like
allah like you know helps them and this
all becomes true um that i i don't think
they're putting on a two-phase but if
they were
um i think they should be held
accountable right for any atrocities any
genocide any misconduct
that they are going to commit against
the afghan people
um and even in the us the u.s government
needs to be held accountable people
living in the us needs to hold the
government accountable for what uh
afghanistan went through in the past 20
years
right so
and i just want to say one important
thing to people posting and reposting
political things and cursing and the
hysteria
um on um
social media that these stuff are not
going to help the people of afghanistan
like and they will never help
those things yeah like i i see um women
posting pictures of um people before the
taliban came to afghanistan uh wearing
like mini skirts like how is that
supposed to help the women currently now
like are you trying to tell them
oh my gosh yeah yeah but you know the
weird thing is that the women who who
call themselves muslim afghan women who
are posting these stuff they themselves
are not wearing the hijab they
themselves are not wearing modest
clothing so they
like i can't blame them because they
themselves have been assimilated into
the western ideology of what it is to a
woman right but a woman like do you
think that if you wear a mini skirt and
a tank top or go out in a bikini right
on the beach that you're not oppressed
you are so much more oppressed
you have 100 men looking at you no
exactly why would you need look look
everyone in this country you can wear
whatever you want argument see but why
would a woman feel
can you think a lot of women are
insecure in the context where even if
you didn't have the beauty industry and
this model looking
every woman feels some kind of
insecurity it's just a woman are you
know the thing is why would can you feel
can you see how oppressed you are that
you have to go out in a bikini let's
look there's a name given to it a bikini
it's made like oh it's a it's a
underwear it's an underwear you're going
swimming with your underwear it's like
you have strip clubs which are called
gentlemen's club
gentleman's club what the hell is
gentlemen what's the gentleman about it
that some perverted man is going there
to have wherever it may be do you get
what i'm trying to say and as muslim men
me and brother
and we're not putting a show on you're
our sister we're very careful to the
words we say and we put limits we're
like okay because of the respect we have
towards you sister you get it i don't
want to go into certain details and
because we have modesty and shyness
towards in front of you that we're
careful too so anytime anybody questions
a muslim man or person we are careful to
our words to a sister marrow i don't
even know sister i don't know you but
you came you messaged me on instagram
and said you wanted to join i know you
as a muslim a believer and me and
brother rahmatullah even when certain
things brother rahman said sister
forgive me
we're very cautious and careful the
stuff we say because the utmost respect
that we have to you because you are our
co-sisters i'm trying to say so we can
in this this is not a setup i didn't
come back to allah make sure you no this
is how we as muslim men are not just
towards muslim women i even when i speak
to non-muslim women when i talk them in
dawah they might be dressed up in an
inappropriate way i refer to them as
sister because i believe every woman
should have a right to be talked to as a
human being not talked to because of how
her body shape is but brother
i've got one minute any last words both
of you guys brother
can you extend the time that can you
extend it okay i i
we can try to do a part two
i'm sure
okay because there are two great after
this like when i'm in part
next week like if this goes good
is it is it possible because you know
what i need to pick my dad up from the
airport i need to leave here about 10. i
have to play maghrib i haven't eaten
yes part 2 would be highly
important so we can go to more technical
details
let's tell the viewers there's going to
be a part two what would those parts
entail let's tell me a bit about the
part two number one the prophet of war
in afghanistan how much americans
himself profited okay number two the
politic geopolitical reason why
americans went there in the first place
yeah and the crime of the black water
and other people have committed the
inner circle of the government and what
is the future for taliban and for the
muslim um okay good in part two we're
gonna cover that if there's anyone
that's watching this if you're another
sister um another but maybe it'll be
good to have i i believe it's very
important to have sister take on this if
there's a sister who is afghani
background um who may i don't know maybe
studied this or whatever it may be um
you can join us with sister mario if
system i want to join again next week
totally up to her we can do part two
inshallah says tomorrow any last words
no no that's it um thank you for having
me and i do believe that a part two
should be a must um there's a lot of
things that um we could talk about
foreign and definitely that's what we're
gonna do brothers and sisters we're
gonna have part two inshallah if you
guys want part two comment in the
section below inshallah and we will have
part two and part two we will discuss
what's on the stake for taliban right
now why they are so kind and nice yeah
and are they truly having their true
face or what's happening so i will share
some internal information inshallah this
isn't
we're not biased towards anyone here
we're discussing and learning and i've
learned a lot brothers and sisters from
until next time for part two you want it
comment in the section below inshaallah
if you want to join us we have one more
person that we can join we can have four
people in sha allah get in contact with
myself uh until next time in sha allah
social media youtube you can follow him
for more updates i'm sure he's going to
be talking about this topic until next
time
bless you guys